okay they start right out the gate with
a bit of a mean question a bit of a bit
of a curveball so we're looking at
question one and this is as you can see
by the topic and this is secrets in the
series so 1b now admittedly it's it's
phrased in a bit of an unusual way find
the values of a and B maybes such that
you form an arithmetic progression out
of those okay any any West Point it's
okay now you can see the way that I have
laid this out if you know if you've been
told that you have an arithmetic
progression out of the game right now
what is it that makes an arithmetic
progression in arithmetic progression
there's a well you're either adding or
subtracting something each time a better
way a more technical way to say is you
have a common difference every time and
the way you can get the common
difference is comparing one term to the
previous one and one term to the
previous one or to the next whichever
direction is fine okay so you can see
therefore why I do this that's
subtracting term for sorry i subtracting
term three from term for if it really is
an AP like they're saying then that
should be the same as term three take
away term two you see what I've done
there and then really this just a bit of
it's just rearrangement a tiny bit of
log gloss but not very much okay so you
see how I've laid it out I was just
trying to find B because it's in that
equation and it's it's closest to the
amount of information that I know I know
some of you might have gotten spun out
by having that base of Z there what on
earth is that about the extension two
kids momentarily panicked because
they're like wait is that what no it
doesn't mean what you think it means
it's just a number and you don't even
know it need to know what the number is
it's all in terms of said okay once you
see by the way he is the first term or
rather he is the first term he is the
second term you can see what's happening
to what's going on in here right you've
got three quarters three on two and then
three and then six so as the term inside
the log doubles the distances between
the whole terms are just constant that's
what an automated prediction is yeah
are you happy with that cool that was
about an AP so here's a GP now in order
to do this well again it was
lightly curveball ish what you really
need to be able to demonstrate was or do
you know how to get the sum of a GP do
you remember we derived this formula
we've got it from scratch but this has
been phrased to you it's been posed to
you in a bit of an unusual way a plus B
plus Z does that mean that there are 26
terms no and the crew is there's no 26
anywhere in the answer the result you're
trying to prove you need to be able to
show okay I know how to get from a whole
series and what did I do to that in
order to get the sum of that series
phrased in more specific or familiar
terms when you've got the sum of the
first n terms right we will usually say
the first term is a that's fine but we
wouldn't normally call the next term be
what we call it for a general GP it'll
be the first term multiplied by a common
ratio right and you'd then do it again
and then you do it as many times as you
needed to until you got to the nth term
what is the nth term it's a and how many
lots of the common ratio n minus 1 okay
now this hopefully when you see it in
this form it's sort of triggers for you
oh I remember now the way that we sort
of collapse this indeterminate number of
terms into something manageable was we
multiplied by that common ratio do you
remember that does it ring a bell okay
so when you do that you can see oh yeah
that's right it creates this parallel
here and this parallel here and all the
intervening terms except that the last
term is an AR to the N minus 1 anymore
is it what is the last term index or a R
to the end because you multiplied
everything by r didn't you okay which is
why when you subtract one of these lines
from the other all of the things cancel
except for except for this guy down the
end and this guy at the beginning to
remember that okay so what I have done
is that exact same strategy except in
this weird-lookin strangely dressed up
formula okay so what I've done is I've
multiplied by this guy where did that
come from what is that that's the common
ratio I know it's not
in a form that you're familiar with but
that's kind of the point of this
question right you can still work out
the common ratio bless you just like we
worked out the common difference in the
previous part okay so I multiplied
through by that and then in the next
line I've done exactly what we did with
the normal proof I subtracted one whole
series from the other and how come I'm
left with just two terms here do you
remember why I'm just left with two
terms what happened to all the rest of
them yeah the same thing that happened
on this side all the intermediary terms
disappeared okay from there it's just a
bit of algebraic dancing around okay I
just need to make s the subject because
that is the question after all show that
it's sum is and then there you are
is that make sense so I know it's weird
that's kind at the point like look at
now that you see the answer here who got
it out first hit anyone yeah a couple of
heads up all right
so most of you now that you're looking
at you're like oh okay I I've done this
before this is familiar right but it's
just inner unrehearsed context and
that's what makes it a bit more
challenging okay